today I'm going to show you a cocktail
called the Tigre Blanco it was created
by Isaac Flores from dick and Janes in
Brooklyn this is a tequila based
cocktail so you're gonna need some of
that some Blanco tequila some fresh lime
fresh OJ triple sec some smoked chili
lime salt and you can buy at the store
and it's some horse shot dub so we're
going to use our first shot the first
two ounces right into the shaker
horchata is a traditional Mexican rice
milk that's been flavored with a variety
of spices typically it's cinnamon and
vanilla you can make this yourself just
by blending rice and water and letting
you sit for a few hours but a lot of
Mexican restaurants also make it so if
you have one you really like you I'm
going to ask them and maybe they'll cite
you some and now our fresh lime juice
just 1/4 ounce
okay half an ounce of OJ fresh orange
juice nothing pizza
now our triple sec ounce of triple sec
and finally an ounce and a half of
Blanco tequila
make sure the bottle says 100% agave on
it that means the only thing that's in
there is a ghave which is what it should
be a lot of tequila producers try to cut
corners by putting other kinds of grain
alcohols and other weird stuff in
tequila because agaves takes so long to
come to maturity sometimes eight to ten
years so just make sure it's 100% agave
on the bottle and you'll be good to go
okay so we got everything in here before
we shake though I'm going to rim our
glass with the chili lime salt rims are
a really cool way to add another
dimension of flavor to cocktails just
rub the edge with lime and dab it in
you've probably used to salt on a
margarita or something but you can use
all kinds of spices and seasonings make
your own mixtures black pepper works
lime zest I like a little sugar I think
it helps to boost the flavor it's a fun
thing to play around with okay so we're
going to throw some ice in our glass and
now it is time to shape we're going to
shake this one super button we're going
to do what's called a whip shake which
is just trying to get the rice milk to
foam up and give the drink really nice
frothy texture
see a really nice foam on top and
garnish with an orange wheel and that is
a tea grade Blanco this is a great
example of a cocktail it draws its
inspiration from food and it's also a
great example of a cocktail that pairs
really well with food so the next time
you're having a really really spicy meal
I recommend keeping us cocktail in mind
if you liked this video and you're
looking for more tips to step up your
bartending game subscribe to the GQ
channel we've got lots more where that
came from